hey audience me and austin it's uh it's
coming up to five minutes uh past the
time we went to start recording i mean
austin just kind of sat here and we've
both been here for five minutes austin
definitely didn't just arrive
wait for it
oh i can't record video
so it might be another one of those
did you seriously do the article video
right now
try it you see what happens zoom is like
you need to be the host and and remember
that was one of those
where there is no host i have i have
much like the person who pretends to be
bad at doing the dishes so they don't
have to do the dishes i've intentionally
never recorded up our show so i don't
know actually i don't even know where
the button is um
wait a minute but i joined first so
maybe i am the host so what do i do oh i
hit the record
no i'm not i'm not the host
yeah i think it's one of those weird
hostless ones because
because you guys joining uh like an
alana link basically
that's how long yeah but i remember she
i remember she couldn't do it either she
records separately in any case we were
waxing poetic about being the only two
who are on time for this morning session
professional podcasters
i think that means we get pro-rated
salaries for this week we're getting
paid
i think uh i think yeah i think we're i
think we i think we get five minutes
extra bonus time taken out of alana and
troy's
uh youtube dollars i asked for like you
know pod pod bucks alana's always
promised me there's no way to monetize
on youtube so so it's fine like we've
we've never she says to me mike there's
nothing there's no way of making money
on youtube no one makes money on youtube
don't you worry about it get back to
work that kind of thing that's what she
says to me i don't know she rolls up in
her
ferrari roma
and is like yeah there's absolutely
nothing to see here yeah
trust me she says trust me don't ask
questions mike get back into the
recording
everything's fine there is a oh my god
i'm sat so i've sat like two stories up
and uh a pigeon just flew like head
first at the window and so my windows
open and the pigeon just flew directly
at me and just carried off at the last
minute but it was i was i was expecting
us to be another guest star in the show
today that was good um
that
makes me realize i have never seen the
reverse angle and i have been a 100
convinced that you are essentially
staring at a computer monitor and a wall
a window maybe a painting or something
yeah it never occurred to me that there
would be a window much less an open
window
how is it not noisy i don't hear
i don't hear like
well i guess it's not a big city center
yeah no there's a train goes by every
now and again other than that we're fine
i've never heard that that's a little
that's a little clue for anyone who's
trying to triangulate my position
it's got to be within ear shot of a
train has pigeons
yeah i mean unfortunately in the uk
that's 50 percent of the uk is where
their shot of a train that has pigeons
that is we love a trade we love a train
in the uk absolutely love a train
i had one of my most memorable slash
harrowing life experiences uh on a uk
train
that's just that's that's that's that's
how trains work in the uk they are
harrowing go on tell me the story it was
it was uh it was amazing um but yeah it
was quite something where i
um
i was
in middlesborough
uh speaking at a conference
and
had to get down to heathrow i left super
early in the day it was like 6 a.m at
the train station it's gonna take a few
hours winding your way through the
countryside down into london it was like
this is going to be great i'm just going
to enjoy my pastoral
sort of visit of the harry potter that's
what you thought was like harry potter
yeah glorious yeah exactly that
and um well especially because
middlesbrough is like almost you know
that newcastle kind of you're like
almost all the way to scotland at that
point you're pretty much at the very
north of england not literally the most
north but pretty like if you take the
train to london you you get to see you
know probably
more than 50 of the the
latitude of of london i would think
um and that was the idea it was you know
i'd been there a bunch of times but it
was always in flights which is like
you know slow-mo teleporting you don't
really get to get a sense of yeah of the
the distance between your destinations
so
i was very excited left first thing in
the morning and my flight wasn't until
i think two or three in the afternoon so
i was going to be able to roll into
london spend the day i had lunch lined
up with a friend uh and then leisurely
make my way over to heathrow and rookie
mistake rookie mistake and well yeah so
i've learned um
i because what happened was
the
day the the the
morning of we make it up
about an hour or two
and we're truly in the middle of nowhere
i wish i remembered literally where but
it felt like
we just were nowhere
and the train just stops and just sits
there and the conductor comes on the
radio and says
be just a couple minutes hang tight be
back with you with an update in a minute
10 minutes goes by 15 minutes all right
is it still yeah this engineers working
on something we'll let you know
another 10 15 minutes sitting there
looking and and i remember there were
these two guys
across the aisle from me
that were very nervous about this they
were very agitated like how much longer
do you think it's going to be is this
and they're like texting the friends
back home is there any do you know
what's going on
they were very productive so i was kind
of like i was getting very absorbed into
their drama
and um
then the conductor finally comes up so
what's happened is
um what would be the what would be the
kind of right outside of london there's
kind of like the big station that
everything routes through essentially
heading into london
there's like one reading maybe or um
i i wish i remembered it's the one and
only time i would have had milton keynes
a lot of the time i'll come i'll go
through on the way from manchester um
there's like one choke point that most
travel into london is going to kind of
pass through
whatever that was reading does feel
right but i can't remember
like some power lines had blown out
across the track
um and basically the result was because
this is a choke point
effectively railway rail movement across
all of the uk stopped i mean it was like
northern ireland was like we're just
gonna we're gonna stop out of sympathy
like it was it was just
absolutely chaos in the railways for
that day while they do the repair
because
this was a particularly vulnerable spot
for there to be a thing that causes this
ripple effect right it'd be like if it'd
be like if jfk
entirely shut down the airport in new
york it would disrupt all american
travel basically
um there are a lot of it every british
person watching this is like oh it's
like a wednesday then okay cool
yeah so i so i learned because yeah
we're sitting on the stopped train for
well over an hour and i remember i
texted my friend and he goes oh he goes
this is actually a pretty big story on
the news right now and he said at this
point
you should just find any possible way
because i was still several hours
outside of london
and so he said you should just find any
way you can to get here because i'd be
amazed if you don't miss your flight
over this
because this is going to be out of
commission for a while so then i start
thinking okay well just whatever it
takes to get to london you know i'm not
hitchhiking distance out of london like
i'm hours
by train away
so i start then clueing on these guys
that are freaking out across the aisle
on the on my train car from me turns out
these were a couple guys from that
newcastle middlesboro area who worked
for
whatever the uk equivalent of like
verizon or att is some
they sold cell phones and there had been
a there had been a company-wide
competition
for top
sales sales of
sale yeah and and the top 20
were
given a um
a uh uh
expenses paid
little getaway in london where they had
a hotel and meals and whatever and then
uh a scavenger hunt had been set up
throughout the city as a prize and they
had rented like 20 mini coopers
to give to the employees to drive around
london go on the scavenger hunt as like
the prize package in addition to
whatever else
and they were texting their boss
frantically going are we going to be
late are we going to miss the start of
it and they were because they were very
excited they had both won this
this prize and you know they're not i
think regular folks in london uh
like they're not city people in other
words so i i was feeling they're
distressed that they were like this is
our big this is like our vacation yeah
yeah
so they were trying to work out if they
could bail off the train go find a
rental car and if the company would
reimburse it since this wasn't their
fault and that would be a fairly hefty
expense to take on last second
so i leaned across the aisle to them and
i go
if you let me come with you i'll pay for
the rental car
sight unseen yeah yeah and they were
like really and so it's like yeah
because i'm starting to worry i'm gonna
miss my flight so we literally just
step off the train in the middle of
nowhere
walk into a little town
that had
a an enterprise like desk with one car
and so we rented the one car
and it was this little car i remember
the two of them sat in the front and i
kind of wedged in the back like the
third wheel and
the american money in the car basically
yeah exactly
facilitated the adventure yeah
and um but so then i mostly and these
were like old friends and they were like
you know so i kind of just sat there and
eavesdropped on them commiserating i
think one of them had a kid recently and
they were just kind of so i was like
this fly on the wall of these guys oh
you've seen
jimmy lately oh yeah you know it's crazy
i heard he got divorced or whatever
their life stuff was good at some point
though they start talking about video
games i'm like oh you guys big gamers
and um they're like yeah oh god hell
yeah you know a lot a lot and i was like
oh that's awesome i was like i actually
work in games and they were like what
the [ __ ] no way like never met anybody
who worked in the industry before so
then they're asking me what games i
worked on like i played that holy [ __ ] i
thought it was like
and um
and so then and then the hilarious thing
was they kept saying like we hate to do
this to you but we're really in a rush
to get to the to get to the thing we got
to get to and um so can we just like as
soon as we get in town can you basically
just jump out and figure out a way to
get to heathrow from there like a cab or
something and i was like guys sure you
you did me a huge favor uh and like
that's not a big deal but we were kind
of up against it with time
they apparently weren't the only ones in
this boat so then this perfect storm
happened where their work called them
and said we're delaying the scavenger
hunt a couple hours you're good then in
that moment they're basically
discovering like you work in games
that's amazing so they started treating
me like royalty you know i guess that
means a different thing there the
american perception of being traded like
royalty and uh so they were like we're
gonna drive you right to the gates sir
and they they gave me this first class
treatment taking me taking me right up
to uh to heathrow and they were and that
funny thing is i'm still every now and
again in touch with one of those guys oh
[ __ ] um that's lovely and family yeah
and it was it was absolutely like the
best case hello we're not recording
video please record the video please
recall
but the story austin's telling has to be
in the podcast
actually yeah now i kind of want to go
to our our friend and get the animated
we need to animate your story
so
they got you there
so then yeah they took me there and it
ended up being like a complete no
like
i by the nick of time i got there which
meant you know my whole day of exploring
london was lost but i got there the
trains were still not working by the
time i got there so it was absolutely
the right decision to have made but it
was absolutely so fun that i had this
like little mini road trip with complete
strangers
uh
and uh you know thanks to apparently
semi-functional rail system in the uk
awesome
that's what you're talking about that
sounds fun what i was gonna say yeah
what's the what's the uh the moral of
the story is
hotels near heathrow are very cheap
listeners okay go down the door
i always
[Laughter]
today
yeah it's uh yeah go to ragnarok has a
release date very exciting stuff um not
that long from now it's not that far off
was it november yep november 9th um
i wanted to talk about this a little bit
because it's been a very weird
experience
in
so the like developer harassment stuff
about not delivering a release date was
way worse than i ever would have
imagined like like just
constant i didn't know like i'm sure
it's not normal for most studios to go
through that
but um
just constant [ __ ] you where is trailer
like so much of it um the god of war i
mean that was gonna be the first thing i
said but i figured i'd let you speak you
technically got one today austin okay go
watch it um
gotowa fans are really wonderful it's
like it's like this weird cross-section
of people who are interested but very
hostile way way way way worse than i
ever would have guessed
or anticipated it was meaning the
release date was was the trailer put out
today as well and it was the fact that
it wasn't until now that you're saying
people were complaining basically people
were very angry that there had been a
length of silence on
the game
um and yeah just like
yeah just pretty much every single day
[ __ ] you wears trailer [ __ ] you wears
release date which to me just seems so
counter-intuitive because you'd make it
just [ __ ] you give me the thing i'm
excited about yeah but you'd think just
wait until it's ready because if you
rush a release date then it gets delayed
or like you end up
like it comes out too soon or whatever
it just seems very counterintuitive but
the the thing that i actually want to
talk about like that stuff sucked again
there are a lot of god of war fans who
are really really wonderful and part of
that fandom that are like constantly
making cosplay and like cool art and
just like excited and very enthusiastic
and really feel like they're a part of
the community like in they almost feel
like a part of the team in a way that's
very very cool um a lot of really nice
god of war fans but the the thing that's
been the hardest to watch from like the
development perspective
is the leakers
who
have just been completely full of [ __ ]
like
and it's almost like you don't know
there's a studio of 400 600 people who
are also seeing everything you say and
being like
what
like like you know that all these people
know that you're lying oh they know that
you can't say anything because i support
specialism right that's their whole
business model so it it it very much
comes across got the cell phone edition
i think
yeah no internet
no internet
thanks for joining us um
yeah it makes you look like you're in a
timeout chair like you look really
isolated and like you're kind of in
trouble
now your time out chair and shut up
what's the point i feel that way today
yeah it's a lacrosse ball
um
i can't wait to hear what conversation
i'm interrupting yeah the audience is
going to be really happy about you
it's like i've been a perfect handoff
because i was finishing a story as alana
joined and we made a hard 180 from that
i don't think alana was finishing though
i think a lot of it was just getting
started
that's true let me get back to what i
was saying when we get troy's lacrosse
ball which will be the title of the
episode
it's
i didn't i okay okay so somebody who's
leaked stuff before occasionally and
then eventually i came to the decision
that i shouldn't do that i accidentally
did it the other week and then it made
headlines and i was like i didn't even
mean to do that i didn't even really
think about what what i had said there
and i also thought more people knew um
but this has been missed that in some
cases absolute nobody's
completely
lying for a few twitter followers like
just making stuff up just so other
people would follow them in a way that i
was like
why on earth would you do that because
the minute that you're wrong which of
course you are
then everyone just knows that you are
wrong and some of them delete their
accounts so they leak stuff and it's
wrong and then they delete their
accounts
why it's such a weird ecosystem
yeah well hmm ecosystem there are a lot
of you know
and and they're arguing with each other
about who's right and it's just this
really bizarre
just just i wonder if they i wonder if
they're like the end i wonder if there's
people lying to them i wonder if like if
there's like a chain going on here
it reminds me i'm fascinated sorry there
was a thread from a popular leaker
recently
who had intentionally leaked things to
another leaker
so that they would catch them out lying
like they had intentionally been a wrong
source so that they could prove how bad
their sources were it's huge i didn't
and and that wasn't even related to god
of war i don't think it's they're just
so many of these people who just kind of
do this full time to get a few twitter
followers who have anonymous names and
they're all competing with each other to
be the best-known leaker
that it it's just it's just so weird
like i i think that they probably partly
contribute to like people being angry
and worked up but i don't think they're
to blame like the shitty people who are
getting angry and harassing people are
the problem like the leakers are just
part of the environment but it's very
very strange to observe because you know
hundreds of people know you're lying
i feel that's a being a bit look i'm i'm
always one for empathy but i think
that's being a bit uh
i'm being too gracious yeah yeah uh it's
it's not it's not the leaker's fault
it's people who get a response you know
respond angrily to that 100
anybody who responds in anger to that on
either side of the defense or taking the
the the plainest part i i think that you
are
responsible for your own reaction
however
the fact that you said a popular leaker
as if that is a
uh one i hate this movie but it's a
hilarious scene
where he goes we call it our broken area
goes i don't know which is more
terrifying the fact that this happened
or the fact that it happened so often
you have a name for it
and that to me is the case of this wait
broken arrow you hate that movie
who can hate broken arrows that's a
great movie
okay well then i'll give you first of
all
okay i i will john whoa
john cute
well
look i can point out a lot i also love
face off but it's not a great movie john
wood is not whoa whoa whoa whoa
don't don't say things you can't take
back troy all right this is this
loves time club
[Laughter]
no [ __ ] i can show you analytics that do
not prove my point
[Laughter]
i just i think that um i to your point
though that that like that leaker
popular leakers would even be a thing
i didn't know until like the last few
weeks i didn't know it was a thing and
then i like found out more about it and
again it was just it's just very
fascinating to read that
like
there are people who
had intentionally or this is one
specific person who had intentionally
been watching um quantic dreams website
and trying to find data for months and
months and months and months just
because they thought that that was a way
that they would find a leak and that's
not technically a leak you just kept
going to the same website to try to find
data and so they were able to leak star
wars eclipse early and then got a
reputation as a leaker because they
shared an image and everybody thought
that somebody from playstation or
somebody from quantic dream i suppose
had sent it to them they hadn't they
just kept going to that website to get
that you've just done that whole thing
for this one reputation
it's very strange to me you've just you
put all that effort into like getting to
be called a leaker
for what as opposed to wow
i guess
but that's the it's low-hanging fruit
it's anonymous and
well that's better you have to deal with
consequences if you're anonymous exactly
and no none of it's real first of all
none of it's [ __ ] real
what is even life is life real are we in
a simulation like what's the what's this
well yeah it's it's it's the notion of
that you know there's any that it's a
commodity that anything that is carried
over
you know by just because a lot of people
see it i mean pt barnum light yourself
on fire the world will pay to watch you
burn that's the whole gig and i think
that there's a lot of people that
if they would just i can't remember who
it was like these people
would be like mensah rocket scientists
if they would apply themselves in a more
productive way
but i think that's the thing i find so
difficult to understand is like the
things you could do this is time
sure but i mean that's like get off my
lawn ism right there
yeah
a lot of them as well are kids
presumably as well right they're making
this stuff up as well so it's like i
don't know i was using that as an excuse
but i'm saying that's we all had too
much time when we were kids and too much
energy this reminds me well i grew up
before twitter and before oh yeah 100 i
would have been awful on those places
i'm reminded i'm i'm into um i'm in the
end of the i'm going to finish my
[ __ ] sentence i'm into um end of the
world uh cults and end of the world
cults have a similar problem where
obviously there's a shelf life on them
because if you say the world's ending by
a certain date and it's amazing watching
how they linguistically turn that around
and go oh no that was a test
like the actual end of the world is this
or the actual like followers i wonder if
that's similar here of like if you can
say if your leagues are false then you
can always come up with like ah well
someone misled me or oh well that was
going to be announced but they chose not
to i bet they're similar that has
absolutely happened over the past week a
lot of people now are like well it
changed
because we're always changing release
dates like in the last week before
announcing them there's not massive
two-month lead times on any announcement
you hear from a major kind of place
definitely not yeah no i i impacted them
so much that they had to change the date
i guarantee you there's people that feel
that way yeah it's it's hard it is a
challenge for me especially given my
experience to but i have to find empathy
for it for no other reason to understand
it so that it makes it smaller
you know what i mean like the second
that you understand what thunder and
lightning is it's not the wrath of a god
and sitting in a cloud swinging a hammer
it's like oh it's electrical discharge
you know in the upper atmosphere i wrote
a book as a kid that i thought about
like rewriting and publishing because i
was originally afraid of thunderstorms
that's about how
uh thunderstorms are actually elephants
in the sky and the stamping and the
bright flashes of them getting you to
smile for a picture so that any kid
who's afraid of elephants and
thunderstorms they're like hey smile and
then the flash is the elephant's taking
photos of you smiling i still have that
book there yeah it's more scary than
lightning though that's the only issue
is i'm more scared of the elephant
they're like smile [ __ ]
that's a gift by the way i'm just
picturing the guy that's the uh
the guy that's driving the olefonts and
return to the king they're like that guy
up on top but now he has a camera he's
just trying to get you to yeah
that's um
yeah i think troy to your point about
the empathy that i i i end up at a
similar place um and although for me
more than i think all three of you
this is always a very kind of abstract
probably of the three of the four of us
this kind of thing affects me the least
uh like i get the downstream effects if
this sort of thing happens in the least
sort of
painful way it's it's like disappointing
but it it it doesn't
and no one ever tweets at me like [ __ ]
you where's the la la la like i think
you'd ever get in blame no it wouldn't
make sense no like because i i think
that you know the people
that are
typically speaking the people that are
going to get worked up about this stuff
don't
they obviously don't know enough about
how the industry works to therefore
realize how crazy it is to get worked up
over it therefore they wouldn't know
about other people in the industry like
me who have a slightly more anonymous
job from their point of view so i i get
the i get the i get the sort of shelter
from that but to that to the point that
i do kind of just abstractly think about
it i do look at it through the lens of
here's a person who has for whatever
reason staked
a fair bit of their time and identity
even if it's anonymously
in terms of what the rest of the
internet knows
they are
clearly sinking
large swaths of their personality and
their time and their use of this life
into that and i go
that's
that's the thing they've got going on i
got to write music for a video game like
yeah so i shouldn't i shouldn't hate
this person i should i should kind of
feel bad i don't think i don't know i
just i'm just like just
why i didn't know it was so much this
big and also they they just disproven so
fast
it's been very weird to watch like to
see tweets that's all the intellectual
side of it though i'm because i agree i
i i'm purely on the emotional side of
just going it's not that i pity them but
i just go i i feel lucky
that there's something more substantive
that i can put my time towards than like
sure hiding behind a twitter thing and
that's now my thing yeah and
fake leaks and i just look at it and i
go
that's that kind of sucks uh and i i
like i wish more for them i wish i wish
them to find something more meaningful
than this that's like where i have to go
that's where i have to go to not just
look at them and go you're insane it's
very confusing
because yeah don't they love it isn't
this theoretically like
beneath it all isn't it this weird
perverse manifestation of a love for
these games well like yeah but i wonder
if it's similar to like a conspiracy
theory type thing where they sort of are
like a lot of them are connecting dots
like the way that everything blew up
with abandoned
was people connecting dots and then from
my perspective at this point
a
creator
playing into those dots for the press i
think that uh hassan at uh the studio
would probably disagree with that but
that's the way it came across in the end
um
so it's it's similar to conspiracy
theories and it's people connecting dots
to feel smart and then
you feel validated because you have more
information than other people and then
you want to tell everyone that you know
more information than them and it's just
it's just validating your existence i
guess it's just i don't know like i said
i don't have hate for them i'm not angry
at them um i do think it like i said
probably contributes at least a little
bit to like some of the harassment
because this wasn't announced on this
day when you said it was well no this
guy who's completely anonymous on
twitter said it was not anyone else but
um again i maintain those shitty people
are gonna be shitty anyway it's just
very weird when it's gonna be disproven
so fast and that hundreds of people know
that
you're not telling the truth it's very
confusing
it's it's gotta be just validation
did you guys watch the uh that netflix
documentary um
i think we talked about this before the
behind the curve was that what it was
the
the documentary about the flat earthers
oh yes that's amazing i've heard it's
really good yeah that's amazing
yeah by the end of it i went oh i
totally get it it's when he's getting
ready for the party right and you're
like oh i understand like they're saying
about why this guy still sticks to it
even though it's been kind of
challenging it's tim getting ready for
the party he's the most important person
in the room because he's the expert and
it's like yeah it's it's just a tragic
kind of moment it's beautiful beautiful
documentary anyways
for that person specifically but also
he's at the top right it's why do i what
about everybody else who's not
uh who doesn't have that prestige with
him clear it's flat earth so everyone's
on the same level
[Laughter]
get out
the um that's a wonderful joke
congratulations on the birth of your son
um
the the thing that i at least the
takeaway that i had from it was
understanding that from someone in that
perspective or from someone in that
situation the world
just don't work
and
that is a scary thing to be able to say
i don't know why
but if i can say oh there's a little bit
of information that i have and this is
why the world don't work and here's a
little bit of inside you know
information that i have that nobody else
has and i'm privy to it so this is
actually why it's not that the it's not
that i'm [ __ ] up is that the world is
and here's the reason why so now
it's con oh yes i think it's a wonderful
way to put it and only that but also i
find community within that fellow people
who want control and so like you said
one leaker talks to another leaker they
found two things that we all want
they found control and they found
community i totally get it i just that
and that's empathy is the only path
through
and it's it's uh it's a struggle for me
sometimes to find that path through
because i i it's easier for me to be
angry my default state is anger
yeah
then again
but the problem is that you have to
extrapolate that
or i have to extrapolate that and make
that go
far and wide that means to everybody
to everything
i'm sorry i have to find
the path to empathy towards everything
and that's that's the real work
for me
i have two questions
what about i felt like some of those
lost of us leakers
i got i finished the game and then i
streamed it on embargo for the last of
his part two
and so i got a new platform i had
already
had already finished it hey guys follow
me on embargo
i had already finished it the embargo
went up when he streamed it
and there were people in the chat who
were wrong about things because they'd
seen bits and pieces of information i
never even saw those leaks so i don't
actually know what happened um
but they'd seen bits and pieces of
information and drawn false conclusions
and were yelling at me because i said
that's not true that doesn't happen
and they were so sure that i was lying
to like help sony or some [ __ ] and i was
like but no you're wrong though and they
were so convinced that they were right
because the bits and pieces i heard from
my friend who didn't play it either they
heard over here that this is actually
out yet
game wasn't out yet and i was like that
didn't happen and then i i was like well
i didn't want to spoil it either so i
just tried not to engage i was like no
no don't worry about it don't worry
about it but that that got so spicy
because they were so sure that they were
right about a thing that they hadn't
even played from leaks that didn't even
give them the correct information really
it was it was it was a wild one to watch
did they also i think this is a phrase
from you
oh yeah
um but i mean that's all proprietary
information um
the
uh
i think austin i think this is a phrase
from you where you said just don't give
it oxygen
and
i've heard that before i probably was
just passing the phrase along
yeah i i love that it's like if if i
want to i can snuff it out
just by ignoring it and that's not
necessarily saying that we should turn a
blind eye to every wrong
uh in in the world i'm i'm saying that
if someone wants to jump into a ring and
fight i also have the opportunity to go
no
it's just if i step into the ring and
fight them i'm just as complicit in the
insanity um
it's the mark is it the mark twain quote
where he says don't don't get into an
argument with an idiot because they'll
drag you to their level and then beat
you from experience
uh something like that it was like it
was
like like
if if if if you are
if you're in a position to know
somebody's wrong the the lack mike's
mike's house is haunted
i'm just uh
it's very windy and i've got the window
open that's what it is but i i don't
know what it is
huh the outside of that door it's a
single hand it's going to come out what
are your listeners mike's door opened
creepily and then closed would give
literally
all of the money i've saved all future
earnings if
rahul's face could appear
oh we have to do that at some point we
have to 100 data
[Laughter]
i want to make sure that i the last time
that i was on airpods uh uh it sounded
like i swallowed a robot you don't sound
like um
okay that's good i also i'm really i
think you're gonna be proud of me mom i
am actually running an audio backup
that's great actually through your phone
asterisk asterisk i started it about
eight minutes ago so
[ __ ] no that's fine it'll be okay that's
all right mike and i started the first
five almost ten minutes i think of the
show with no video also so well you did
immediately tell me so well hey
108 episodes we're getting we are
learning a lot we have taken a failing
and we have turned it into a learning
experience and we are doing better as a
result we are
it's growth it's growth it's you know
i'm proud of all of you but to end the
ragnarok conversation on a positive note
it's gonna say like everyone was super
excited it's so it's it's it's very cool
it's so cool to see the positive
reaction like people are just super
hyped and
uh it has largely been a very positive
day for a lot of people so that is
wonderful it's just it's so cool to have
something out there to have everyone
know what it is and be able to talk
about it no yeah it's great when it's
coming yeah and obviously like when that
was so anticipated it was an exciting
thing to get to reveal so
you know another collective is so cool
and i'm very excited to like
to see fans but speculation come out of
what people think of certain things even
just of that it's gonna be fun to watch
because those god of war fans can be
pretty hardcore and it's a it's a
delight i cannot wait to watch people
stream the game i cannot wait
i am so excited
i think another aspect
go ahead regardless
like because there's going to be people
that like like you said there are
hardcore fans out there there's going to
be people that inherently love it or
hate it right
are you excited are you do you have
equal i message is a straight question
no
it's not like i would reject the people
who don't like it i think that's totally
fine what i'm excited for is the
hardcore fans
like going through the story and being
like this one and this character and
this guy i'm excited to see the
excitement like that's what i'm looking
forward to it's not regardless but that
doesn't mean that i think that i would
have any issue with people who don't
like it that's obviously expected cool
with those two but excited to see the
people who like cry or whatever like
that's what yeah
it's gonna be fun
yeah austin what i was gonna say was
that the the thing that
i think could be also
the the other aspect
of the
leakers just slash random
the broad just trolls in general who
will who will give [ __ ] to people for
anything really online
something that i've also observed
through again my comparatively limited
experience with that kind of thing
is that
i think
there is a perception that folks like us
but particularly also like the the neil
druckmann's or corey barlogs or ken
levine's or the tim schaefer's the
really high profile like project
director level folks on these
games that would have this huge
marketing campaign there's a certain
sense of they live
so removed from the world that
they'll they'll this person would never
acknowledge me
but
maybe if i make enough noise they might
actually do so because the number of
times that i've seen it again i i am
coming at this from a very different and
comparatively much narrower angle but
even just
last week for example
someone on our youtube comment on here
said like austin tell your stories
faster or something like that
so i wrote this like 3 000 word response
i saw that and their with their response
was like holy [ __ ]
they were like i didn't well i was like
walking so i was just dictating it on my
phone it was very low friction way to do
it
yes i'll miss so but the point is
their response was like i i wasn't and
in fairness they were not like a troll
they weren't like super harsh or mean or
whatever so they're not
overly familiar is one that happens a
lot on social media yeah yeah like they
were doing banter like you were a friend
but obviously at a distance yeah
and they were kind of poking and
offering a
you know a not an insubstantiated
critique also but the point is they um
their response was i wasn't expecting a
response yeah like hey nice to meet you
kind of like like the number of times
that i've responded on my own youtube
channel uh where somebody writes a con
like if you look at my videos i
routinely respond to people on my face
and then i get the same thing where
people go i don't expect you to reply
yeah i get it i get it all the time and
it's it's weird for me as well a lot of
them i'll get sent a lot of stuff that
reads negative but then
i've had to learn to kind of pass that
as no this person has this kind of
parasocial relationship with me maybe
they think this is like we're buddies
and they're like joking and often i
think i've like told someone off a
little bit and been like hey that's a
weird thing to send to a stranger on the
internet and they've been so embarrassed
by that and it has happened like like
yours and it's happened to me so many
times where it's like okay so i try and
navigate that now with a lot i try and
give people
i give too much benefit of the doubt to
a lot of people on the internet just to
kind of like okay this person maybe is
and i can do that because obviously i
don't get as much abuse as many people
do but like it's
there is this weird yeah it's the
parasocial thing i think people i think
i invite banter from strangers and
as soon as you're on a podcast and
people here you talk one hour a week
like i feel like that's done like they
they they hang out i had it before i had
it before but yeah that's that's awesome
it's your face then i don't know
i just look like a guy you want to look
like a guy
i get it i don't think that leak is the
nicest thing anyone's ever said to me a
lot of thank you never worries anything
about that that's really what i'm going
to
do
for responses from official sources like
a director because that undercuts
them that makes their knowledge wrong i
think they don't want people to reply
they just want to be they want to gain
the followers and then it's it's like
the nft scams where people just what are
they calling it like rug pulls
where people just like make a bunch of
money and then sort of run away
but the rug pulls them more specific
where it's like people have made
millions of dollars and then shut down
projects and just like liked it like i
feel like it's kind of how you end point
of every nft though eventually there are
rug pulls and there are nfts that have
not yet rug pulled you're probably right
yeah yeah but my argument is only
because pulls that leak is it pulling
out from under you yeah
yeah
they're getting a bunch of followers by
kind of connecting something slightly
and then it turns out to be wrong and
they delete their account and it's
irregular it's the same thing it's just
for temporary
charlatans perform best in uh in a
vacuum right because you haven't if you
have no if you have no counter evidence
to what you're saying be it a corn or be
making something up about games release
like they are best served by companies
not announcing anything because that
gives them more more space to
yeah it was also in the old west you
never saw a snake oil salesman that had
brick and mortar he was always on the
move
it's incredibly intuitive and probably
totally historically substantiated that
you you couldn't afford to stick around
because you'd essentially probably get
run out of town anyway yeah
that's so funny it's such an obvious
sort of like how can that not
and it's the same thing it's just that i
can understand a snake oil salesman a
little bit more because the snake oil
salesman is trying to feed a family in
theory
they're trying to make money
it makes slightly more sense there's
more an obvious motivation there rather
than a kid who's got an anonymous
account that's fair yes but that is the
the for especially for the
the like mike said with their likely
kids
they aren't
they they don't have to
they don't have to earn a living most
likely these are presumably kids in like
growing up still or like a lot of this
is driven by
folks who are
they're not
you know this is not an after like
nights and weekends activity for them
yeah because they're not in that
position like i i have nothing to back
up what i'm saying i just it it would
not strike me as wrong
if somebody i i would it would feel very
intuitively agreeable if somebody said
yeah you know this is the sub 18
demographic is the is the is the fuel
all it takes is one person to tap into
that market
uh
you know and and also not preoccupied
with earning a living smart people tend
to assume smartness in the past other
people's decision making like alana
you're thinking about this in like uh
what are they getting out of it way
because you're someone who thinks about
things on that level and not everyone
thinks about things at that level a lot
of people work on very quick instinctual
kind of interactions i watched a netflix
documentary series i wish i could tell
you the name but there's an episode on
swatting the phenomenon of calling a
swat team to somebody's house and you
know saying there's a hostage situation
or whatever
um a guy went to jail for swatting
got out of jail went right back to it
didn't stop him from swatting he did it
again
and they had some interviews with people
who had been swatting and the whole
thing for that like it was very
interesting and i don't feel like i
really even understand it more it was
just power the whole thing wasn't they
weren't even that worried about getting
caught it was just knowing
having that an impact on something that
you're watching and then you know this
this guy a guy died
because they got swatted and the guy who
was responsible for the swat was just
like i'm not the one who leaked the
address so blame the guy who gave me the
because he actually gave him the wrong
address so he leaked he swatted a random
person's house and someone got shot like
and then he was just like
like it was very
i don't know it's worse enlightening
like i understand it less
the pets always get hurt right because
it's like
policy to yeah yeah
it's a horrific thing that i guess
people just addicted to power
they just want to
feel like they have power again control
i think maybe that's like just a state
of human kind that we just
need to feel like we have control over
certain things in certain ways troy
keeps leaving and i don't have control
over that it's making me anxious
i'm guessing it's troy's screen falling
asleep it's what it is right it's going
to
no it just went joining and when i was
joined that's strange
yeah i mean isn't that
ironically isn't that sort of part of
the whole premise of quite a few games
in general anyway like the whole concept
of the power fantasy isn't that the
driving force of huge swaths not
obviously not all games but
but just
tapping into this deeply human instinct
to need to actually
one of the one of the most
cool things i ever got to be part of i
think i've mentioned it on here before
but the first time i met the group from
australia tripod was when they reached
out to me to do a show with them with
the melbourne symphony
uh called this gaming life
and there's a song in there the way the
original premise was i was gonna
orchestrate these songs they were
writing and then we all ended up just
kind of
making this this show together and um
and but there's one song in particular
that they wrote
that i think is kind of
among our favorites on the whole thing
it was called safety in numbers
where he's talking about
a road rage incident that he genuinely
scott from tripod got into a road rage
incident
somewhere in australia where someone
just like really freaked him out like it
escalated in a way that seemed
completely insane
and he's juxtaposing that to like
signing into world of warcraft
where he goes
the most insane thing that can ever
happen to me in this game
was still created and planned
and there's a an element of control that
if i don't have someone somewhere has
and he goes through the real world
things happen
in ways that are random and have no
explanation there sometimes things just
don't go a good way sometimes horribly
uh even if it's like a natural disaster
never mind human it can feel unfair but
there's no logic to it whatever yeah and
so that was what the title safety and
numbers refer to the idea that there's
an underlying sort of code base to games
that there's a there's a security
blanket in that realization but there is
always in societies as well like you can
only get swatted in countries where
swatting is possible
right what do you mean
but what city can you not call the cops
well we we don't give our cops guns in
some countries
[Laughter]
that's you know that's what i'm saying
is there's a society i'm not you know
knocking america on this but like we we
we choose our we we build cultures to
create allowances and affordances the
way austin's saying like game designers
like if your military if your police is
militarized then that changes the the
rules and i imagine there are a lot of
history oh one hundred percent one
hundred percent that's however
the set of interacting systems that
create the the range of of hurt that can
happen or the range of dangers and risks
in society you know there are and every
country's got them right every country's
got like it's things all of those police
like how they'll respond is different in
every country yeah yeah i am there's the
average person that's walking around in
the uk is is not armed with a machine
gun but there is obviously a police
they're the level of the police force
i've seen them that have [ __ ] weapons
go to an airport in thailand and they've
got i can't get them to come to your
house
you know
yeah
you're not going to get some
yeah that's the nicest guy yeah yeah
really
related but jumping away from the
military my single least favorite video
game writing trick and i'm so surprised
that i never see people talk about this
the one thing that i it makes me
uncomfortable and it's very common
is when you do something in a video game
that is planned it's linear you are
supposed to do this thing but then every
npc character starts telling you how
amazing you are every every character
around the player goes that was
incredible are you the one who slayed
the dragon oh that was amazing i'm like
you're saying this to every [ __ ]
player because of course you are oh i
don't think that it was designed for me
to do it just it freaks me out i'm
always like stop pandering to me
the opposite where the game's like you
did that thing you had to do you monster
i prefer that i think
i can't stand it like it's so i can't
think of a good example of what you're
talking about like i'm sure you would
have seen it in virtually every rpg like
you do the the protagonist does
something and everyone else goes
fable they start clapping when you walk
past
maybe any game that has like like
infamous did this too or or
um miles morales did this like
spider-man does this in any game that
has some kind of like morality system
uh in play where it's how are you
necessarily playing this and the world
can respond to you
um i never thought about it do you think
that that's late not i don't know
i'm using a term that just quickly comes
to mind i'm not necessarily being
disparaging but would you consider that
lazy writing are you saying
it's just purely a trope in the sense
that you're just observing that it
happens but you understand why it
has to be because
right so like that's what it is and i
think that the power fantasy doesn't
appeal to me so therefore the trope
stands out i don't know i
i i think that it's to me i look at that
as going i want to affect the world
uh i i want my decisions to matter right
so good for good or bad it's not like
that's power i'm in control
right but what i'm saying is that's not
what i want i just want to feel like the
reason why i'm playing a game is because
i'm i'm it's it's immersive and i find
myself in it and i'm as completely
connected to it as possible
and if the world's not responding to me
then i i i want it to res bioshock if
there's a perfect example
um
you're standing there in airship and the
husband is calling to the wife just
saying just jump just jump and you know
we've got to get out of here we can come
i'll catch you just jump but she's
crying to him and i could walk out of
her and i could swat her i could do
whatever i wanted and i wasn't affecting
the world i want the world to respond to
me
um i think as well though
with with this as well i think it's i
don't know if it's laziness i do think
games writing as a
i think i feel like we're getting better
i think writing like traditionally
you always want consequences in writings
you always want to acknowledge like oh
character did x therefore y
but with um with interactive narrative
where the player is either making
choices or not making choices the intent
and the and the uh degree of choice the
per player had
should define the the scale of the
outcomes and that's something that's
kind of very still up for grabs like
it's still there's great games writers
who are very good at this but that's why
we're getting some weird vestigial stuff
where like
you know the goodies the the go-to
example is what i was saying of like of
the game that kind of tells you off for
doing the thing you had to because in a
movie all the actors have to do the
things that the script says they do and
and in the order that they say they will
so we can we can have those kind of
morality plays play out and we're not
thinking about intent or choice beyond
what the characters in the in the
fiction are doing whereas in games we we
do have this additional layer that we're
almost talking past the characters in
the game when those characters are
applauding you in the mmo they're
applauding
the character you're playing as but
they're also applauding alana and that
dichotomy between
actor and player and character and all
of this stuff
that's the thing that writers i think
are still
in the very early stages in games kind
of figuring out that's probably part of
it but i also feel like it's the current
limitations of narrative design in
general is that like if there aren't
systems in place to figure out how to
give people
uh a sense of impact on the world it's
it is it's not laziness on anyone's part
but it is easier to write a few lines of
dialogue and say i saw you did this
because they haven't yet figured out the
systems that somebody needs to program
to make you feel like you have an effect
like
can you give me an example of what
another system would be like world art
reflecting it uh like dying like two had
very small shades of as you um
claim an area though you can choose the
streets or the you choose a faction to
align with and they're basically good or
bad i guess
and one of them will change all the
rooftops and you'll have more water and
there'll be more flowers and the others
will have more traps to capture zombies
so it would be like instead of even
being like wow look at you
you saved the water tower the water
tower would now have people on it there
would be growth there would be a garden
so things like that that that i said
dying like two didn't in very like
restricted ways but i think that the
systems don't exist yet there's also an
economic problem as well which is
interesting and this is where alana's
right that as these systems get better
and cheaper which is always what happens
in games it'll get easier but like
legibility is a big thing so when you're
if you're adding a feature to a game any
any feature you would add to a game
costs money like it costs time for
someone to do it salary uh whatever like
there's there's always a cost associated
with anything so anything you add to a
game you're always kind of having to
justify that choice be it a blade of
grass or a character or whatever so with
story it's interesting because um story
doesn't like good beautiful fluid
narrative systems like alarms describing
are often invisible there's a just a
really simple example of this in
subsurface circular game we made there's
a character who you basically at certain
point in the story can like basically
call them a name
and whatever name you choose to call
them that will then keep coming up and
they'll keep referring back to the fact
that you called them that and they'll
make little snide remarks about it and
you know i was watching a playthrough of
that the other day and the player
never noticed it
all of that work to create that fun
little outcome because the player
doesn't see the story branching out and
doing its different things this is why
something like detroit has that screen
of all of the mapping of everything it's
kind of
story
more so than like something flashy and
visual story branching and story
outcomes players are very used to the
kind of fake reaction that alonso amount
of characters all applauding you for the
thing you had to do that they are not
trained to look out for that stuff so
immediately the person budgeting the
project the person kind of figuring out
where people should spend their work
goes well we don't no one's going to
notice that the nickname is being
carried over and make it made reference
to later so let's cut that in a game
like subsurface circular that's fine
because it's just me writing text it's
really cheap but in a triple a game
where that requires a voice act or a
mocap session and blah blah blah like
there's you know these these things
often get knocked out the game that like
really stood out to me recently i was
playing through forza horizon 4 for some
reason um i love those games they're all
very good that's the the british one and
i would you know do something i would
finish 10 get to level 10 in whatever
career and the
radio not even a person would go wow
that was amazing can't believe you did
that and i'd be like but that's
i don't know that's how they all sound
it's ridiculous they they all sound like
that's how you look
okay
look at you go and i was like okay but
you you that's what the game is the game
is me supposed to do that someone just
over a radio talking to me because you
get to name yourself and you're supposed
to look like yourself as well is telling
me how [ __ ] amazing i am i'm like so
uncomfortable with it i don't know why
i'm always like
like i i wish i could pinpoint why it
creeps me out it's i think it's that i
feel like i'm being pandered to
and maybe it's that i'm picturing the
person
who thrives off of that and that's where
the discomfort that makes you i wonder
if that's something we're going to get
to at some point in the future of like
because we talk a lot about like
narrative designing games as being about
the outcomes of systems within the game
i wonder if we'll ever get to a point
where also games are structuring and
making their choices with narrative
based on the audience so someone like
yourself who doesn't go to games looking
to be seen in that way and looking to be
celebrated in that way
the game goes ah alana has a different
set of interests or like a different
there's a different reward we can give
alana with this story and arcs in that
direction that's my point it's like i
don't think it's lazy right and i think
it's just a limitation of the systems
like that that narrative design is
effectively a new job it's not even
defined it means a different thing at
every single studio every job listing so
many did you see the flowchart thing
someone posted it on twitter where it
was like all the different jobs that are
called narrative designers so many
different things so it's like i think as
that book it's game design 20 years ago
that's what it is yeah so there's a
there is an example of this where the
conceit of that is kind of baked in it
happens both under the hood and also
above so it's very visible to the player
which was shadow of mordor in shadow of
war where you do have
characters that are speaking to you
reflecting intentionally the choices
that you've made
whether that be so it's it's a system
plus it's the
the kind of like the easy way but the
world also responds to you they're like
it's the conceit of the game is the
systems that they put in place
to purposefully respond to you and the
world does change even so much so like
if you die the fail state was so much
fun because it was like the world
changes and there are procedural things
that happen
based upon
your death how you died by whose hand so
that to me like is is where and i think
that's one of the reasons why the game
won game of the year or
for i think it won something in the year
but didn't win dice it was so funny um
is because that was very innovative and
was pointing to what you're talking
about to where
eventually there will be right now for
the most part it's easy to do text it
feels 100 yeah in that game and i think
like i said part of the problem with it
is the pandering of knowing that that's
being told to everyone no matter what
regardless and that some people take it
too hard like it's collecting you back
at yourself in that way yeah i guess
like and and also journey did the same
thing seize you
the
journey did the same thing
based upon
well
we should get on to warner brothers
lawyers because you're not allowed to do
the same thing with shadow before yeah
austin it's not a lot of people praise
the nemesis system and journey so this
is nice
no you mean in terms like the morality
system troy or
no i'm saying it as far as like player
input determined there was a system that
was put into place to that
in a very innovative way that wasn't
just way to go you did a good job your
trophy unlocked her a
an npc applauding you or berating you
but like the music would change
depending upon what you did so there
were systems would you say that was more
player agency or player input or would
you say that was just more
it's definitely a player
input but journey is also pretty linear
so
i'm mostly just making sure that the
music
is
following suit with where the player is
within that linear storytelling so i
don't think it's quite the same
thing that you're like you can't you're
not affecting the world you're going
through the stages
um that have been laid out for you i
think the shadow of war example is a
really
or a mordor well both but that's a
that's definitely bang on a feeling like
i
actually did a thing
that has consequences um
i it's funny
to that end
um and and bringing back to something we
talked about ages ago that i never i
only
like
never brought up
here
uh was i did finally play through death
loop
um
uh
and
that
that's probably the one thing i wish
there was more of in that game because
they narrative just kind of like hades
and a bunch of other games they kind of
narrativize your death as much as what
you're doing like the al there's no
there's nothing that exists outside of
the game in the
load game over restart like it's all
part of the story
um it would be cool if there was
uh if
it seems like that game has opportunity
to make the world
dynamically adjust to your participation
in in that
loop because it's aware of it in other
words if every time you died
you know
uh
like this character that was always
going to be over there is now over here
because
there's a certain reaction to understand
it yeah like
uh
there would be it would be interesting
if if um i mean look it's easy to just
say that the game is crazy complicated
in its systems already
um and it's such a cool
like
conceit i really loved it and also i
think a good example of everyone knows
who cult is you're reading about cult
all the time everyone's going cult oh
[ __ ] cult oh [ __ ] cult's doing this but
i was always very interested rather than
feeling pandered to because i was like
what is happening and what has called
done because i'm playing as somebody who
also doesn't remember
so you you the the player and the
character at the exact same point
learning the same amount of information
it didn't feel like pandering they just
know okay here to shut [ __ ] down are you
saying there's a lack of ludonarrative
dissonance i am thank you
there you go but i i do think it we
learned something all together i love
deathly i really really really enjoyed
it
it was it was great it just it it really
um
that was the one thing i remember
wishing is like oh man if i because one
thing that they did that's cool
is
if there's like a password you need to
get into uh a thing you can't go google
it uh online like it randomizes it for
your playthrough um and if there was a
certain if there was if it was possible
to make some of the bigger picture
things
not necessarily randomizable but
changeable such that if i die the the
characters somehow learn from that and
get better in the same way the nemesis
system is sort of like trying to kind of
one up in order to face off against you
that would have been the one thing that
i would have loved because it would have
felt very natural within what they
already built it wouldn't have felt like
this
external for sure yeah i mean like you
said that game is already very
complicated and i think there's a world
where that game in ten years they would
know how to do that um i had budget for
that kind of fee like mike said adding
features exactly
one visionary who is fully aware of the
loop
wengie
is the scientist that's like in 20
places at once yes and then i think
maybe there's one other guy who they're
aware of the loop but like everyone else
thinks it's day one the whole time so
it's like there's also one door that's
not randomized which is the first run
right because they give you the
achievement if you guess it correctly
because it's also written in that room i
think for is it also oh that kind of
that's i i would i
liked guessing it i liked successfully i
felt smart and i got an achievement
too
it's something that i think stands out
to me a lot that i never see anybody
talk about that i do think is probably
solved by the progression of narrative
design and like you said the cheapening
of narrative design i don't think it's
lazy writing i think it's just in a lot
of cases the only option to make players
feel like they have an impact outside of
say like there are older games like old
wasteland i feel like made me feel like
i had a [ __ ] impact because something
would i mean even fallout 3 like that's
wasteland dna you blew out megaton now
megaton's not there anymore and that's
an example of like and then not
everybody comes to you and goes you're
the one who blew up mega time that
doesn't happen the game doesn't pander
to you about it because people don't
even know that megaton blew up in a lot
of cases you just can't get to those
vendors or get those quests anymore i
think that's no satisfying
as a side note i think it's one of my
favorite things in any video game that
the reason to blow up megaton is because
the guy in the tower thinks it's ugly
yeah uh the nicest it's literally
it's like the yeah it's the guy who
lives like in the penthouse or whatever
i remember thinking that was so
hilarious uh that like it's this whole
big elaborate quest
to set off the bomb and then it makes
this huge irradiated crater where
megaton was and the player's reason to
do it is you want to see what it looks
like you're like what happens when i do
that like because you don't give a [ __ ]
about the apartment building i don't
think they give you an apartment or
anything i don't think there's like a
huge gain for it
but there are a lot of people in that
building that are like uh megaton
which again i still have three i think
it's almost like there's some satirical
thing they're trying to get across in
that moment i couldn't work it out i
couldn't see that oh no they'd go hard
on it they go hard on it but it's they
don't even hide away from it fallout 3
is in my top 10. i love that game yeah
that's one of the few games that's of
that length and scale that i played
through entirely more than once yeah i
almost never
um
just have that many hours to commit you
know multiple like 40 to 50 hour
playthroughs but i just loved
i loved everything about it i loved
scrounging around and the endless
[ __ ] sewers and the
ghouls and i mean it's just like
yeah
i i've i i think we've talked about it
here before as well ghoul's like adam
driver does and it makes me very happy
as opposed to how
it's just a way that adam driver says
what movie is that he's he's in like a
zombie movie yeah i i wonder follow up
austin's as opposed to how how else do
you say ghouls
i guess i just mean with an american
accent please continue
adam driver
all americans the american
uh
the
uh i know we've mentioned it also here
divinity original sin two
is another one of those games that the
the elaborateness of the narrative
agency the player has
and is is actually insane i don't know
that that's i feel like that as popular
as that game is
i don't see it
heralded as like the narrative design
achievement that i feel like i don't
think it's that popular like it is like
it's not not pop it's not like it's
niche but i don't think it's popular
enough to be a part of the conversation
that's a travesty because the sheer
amount of control you have and just
thinking about the amount of dialogue
because it's it's all voiced so the fact
that they have like thousands of
versions of every conversation because
you have all these different npcs like
all these different um
characters you can play at like your
party can be comprised of and there's so
many variables that will change like the
the the number of ways where you enter
it and
if you're if your party was different by
one person that one npc will react
differently and open up a whole quest
that you'll never even know was there uh
and it's all voiced and there's items
and that stuff is so complicated that
most studios will just go
no yeah no [ __ ] that and they're like
it's strange
it gets
because what's the return on investment
for the average game like it's it's
like yeah you put all that into the
writer of gears 5 and i wish that i
could remember exactly what he was
saying about this uh tom bissell as it
were
um writer of disaster artist person i am
most frequently mistaken for in
interviews that's why i enunciated it so
specifically i wonder if he gets that
with me if you if you if you if when you
talk to him again ask him if he's ever
mistaken for me because i'm often
mistaken for him and i would it would
make me feel it wouldn't surprise me at
all
if it was the other way around as well
if it was reciprocal that would make me
happy okay probably
by the way tom um yeah please tell me
about
how
there are certain choices that you make
where the dialogue will be completely
different and he was like checking
reviews to see if anybody noticed and
just nobody did because people didn't
play through that game twice or pay
enough attention to those chunks of
dialogue close enough
so that's why it's hard for a lot of
studios to justify is most people don't
even see it what exactly that's that's
the challenge and and until i feel like
shadow of war was it's frustrating
because it felt like it was the start of
a moment where the audience was reacting
well to this kind of like investment
um and unfortunately it didn't start
that moment which which is a shame but
um
it'll come there'll be another there'll
be another bigger budget game that takes
a risk on this kind of thing and totally
again i maintain that's like the most
exciting thing about working in video
games is that that like where we're at
now
we're not limited by ideas we're limited
by hardware really like cost is still
memory in a lot of cases like we're just
limited
in so many ways that like as people
learn and as those ideas become possible
and it's not really do you think it's
more do you think it's more hardware
than money do you think it's more the
hard way than that i look at them being
one in the same like in that in theory
as the hardware gets better the things
are cheaper to implement it's not a it's
not a cost of like well we have to take
this puddle out to put this light in
because that's all we can afford we can
only like
that's like a three-hour debate but i do
disagree with you i want to do that
episode i think it's both
yeah
but when i say cost of video games i'm
usually talking about memory
i think i'm usually talking about memory
especially with triple a then i wouldn't
say the money is being spent
on the hardware as much as it is on the
contents of the assets or the
production my theory is that
hardware will make those things cheaper
that's almost certainly true yeah that's
fantastic well
but there are certain things that
like
if you have a if you have a software i
guess things like unreal uh the new
unreal's gonna like
allow a whole bunch of new people to get
into game dev and do a bunch of creative
[ __ ] that they never would have ever do
before
yeah hopefully
but you
there's a certain amount of um
like if you have a game of 100 000 lines
of dialogue some like huge
open world
you know
there's there is no way
to reduce the cost
the hardware doesn't factor into the
cost of the astronomical cost of the
actors and the writing in the studio
time and they're human classes
like that as we solve the ai voice issue
right unless everybody unless troy and
the programmers can figure out a way
that troy can voice over those
characters virtually with ai
i feel like that's going to happen with
art it's going to happen with animation
there are some things that ai will will
help with with a lot of that i think
it's it i yeah what what ai and program
and code in general is brilliant at is
taking over the stupid part of clever
people's jobs that's the thing it's
really good out i don't think it will
ever replace but it will definitely
streamline
like we're already using ai in some of
our processes in ways i can't really
talk about but like it's it's an
interesting frontier but it doesn't
replace you know people it's it's it
just gives
a head start i guess
but i i can tell you in a case of like
this this project um it's a shame that
troy has yeah just disappeared more
thoroughly disappeared this time coming
back i think um the um the by the way
hold on do you have to go back to work
are we are we cool
don't you have a job you have to get a
job uh i
do but i wanted to take up the full hour
so i can do like another five minutes
this is my lunch break that's how i do
it so i always just stick to an hour so
and i don't eat
good that's because me and austin were
doing the the story i wasn't here
stories high with me and austin you
weren't here my meeting went overtime
and here i am having lunch
that's how we make it work
the um this
musical stray gods yes is one where the
sh the branching
i mean there's many many many thousands
of outcomes uh that the game like
thousands of viable distinctly different
playthroughs
um uh
that the game
creates and obviously from a songwriting
standpoint had to support all of that
and and i kept constantly finding ways
to go oh wouldn't it be cool if
if this had this impact and this then
had this and but you do reach a point
where you go
i'm going to be making content for the
rest of my life if i say yes to all of
these things
uh or if they tell me yes to all these
things like at some point yeah it it so
it it hardware and software never
figured into it so much as just the idea
that
that the
we have to we have to record we have to
ship the thing at some point we have to
ship the things
you know yeah
yeah like like it and also even though
on a game like that we're already well
into the territory of
like there are i am certain there are s
there are moments
where
we spent ages on the writing and then we
spent ages in the booths with the actors
and then i've spent ages in the
post-production and mixing and
orchestration process there are already
i know like thousands of hours sunk into
moments that probably less than one
percent of players will ever even know
are there yeah um
that i get a weird thrill i also think
it's super cool out of that i i like i
like that the game
has this kind of bell curve where at the
edges
are going to be content where very few
players likely find themselves and i
love the idea that they go
i tried this and then this and i can't
[ __ ] believe that such and such
actually was sort of accounted for as a
scenario when someone finds that right
it's like someone found that you can you
can sing you can sing like a song from
hamilton in in again some service
circular and when the first person
posted the image of them achieving that
i just i was saying there was a bunch of
stuff in the witness that the community
was figuring out in real time after that
game came out that was so [ __ ] cool
to watch or the fact that the language
had a real actual what's name just came
out yeah
um there was a real thing buried in the
woods
um
uh from inscription yeah um like nuts
so yeah that that that um
that
i i recognize that from a producer who's
in charge of the money
it is a difficult thing to
defend it kind of reminds me of the
story where neil degrasse tyson was very
troubled by the fact that
in titanic
when they're floating on the wreckage
and they look up at the sky it's the
wrong sky for that time of day and that
part of the year and what and not and
not just that but it it's half a sky
that's being mirrored
uh like they have a half a sky image oh
no
and so he
had an occasion to meet uh james cameron
years later and he was like
you you made such a marketing point of
talking about how detailed and accurate
this movie was that every every like
nail on the deck board was a a period
authentic nail and like
you all but rebuilt the titanic and yet
the sky something so knowable
um and so seemingly cheap to get right
and cameron's responses reportedly to go
imagine how much more money we would
have made if we got that detail
that's a good point and i mean there's a
lot of stuff that like there are costs
now like when we talk about game
development
people who are figuring out the thing
now in theory becomes cheaper once the
people have figured it out because then
the next time they implement it it's a
lot easier the longer a studio is around
technically the cheaper some things get
because you can take ai from one game to
another game and just like keep
iterating and the iteration's obviously
a lot cheaper than making it from the
ground up so
you still have to hire a lot of people
you can't i don't think we can get rid
of actors i think a lot of stuff can be
procedurally generated we're probably
going to see more and more of that i
don't mean like a procedurally generated
dungeon i mean more environments
than the audience realizes already trick
more is than the audience realize in
terms of like open world games for
example like more is than people know
yeah and we'll just get more of it and
it'll get better and thus things will in
theory get cheaper which means other
things can get better which i think is
very exciting and related to that mic
it's a shame choice on here um
kojima choosing to partner with
microsoft and specifically citing the
cloud as a reason for it what do you
take that to mean
because i have no idea
there are so there are so many answers i
i
what's the appropriate answer for this
publicly facing podcast
i think i think that's an interesting
talking point
and i wish all parties are the best
um i think i'm picking up what you're
putting down you think it's marketing
okay
because i i i don't i don't guess what
that i don't
it means nothing
it's it and but to be clear it's hideo
kojima so he might have a brilliant
i mean impossible to imagine idea that
we're all going to take the piss out of
three years and then it's going to come
out and we're all going to be like oh
like what was the genre he called death
stranding
strange it was it's a social story
yeah i think but then it releases
and i get it like i get a social strand
[ __ ] video game and it's like and
it's like i'm never going to [ __ ]
take the piss out with you could you
bring it
you know fair play so so maybe there's
reality to it to me that's a a
differentiator you can mention with xbox
i'm sure it's more to do with that's
where there was an interesting
opportunity to make the game you wanted
to make that would be that's most
developers maybe don't even know how you
can make a different game
because of
the cloud as it stands right now
presumably you cannot in my small
subjective perspective on this but hideo
kojima may be onto something
yeah yeah [ __ ] it i will
always in the face of yokojima stadia is
you're regardless of execution the
premise of that you don't need hardware
but it's still the same game being
streamed from like kojima
alluding to the cloud makes me think
that that the game will in some way be
more adaptive than just game streaming
which is stadia like
the cloud just means
it's stored somewhere
but i don't yeah i mean the the term the
cloud is often used as this sort of
panacea of all things
yeah exactly it isn't it isn't exactly
anything mystical
um
but you know i don't know i do i do
occasionally see these experiments of
you know what the less we depend on the
player's personal hardware
depending on the kind of game
like imagine if there was a thing
imagine if there was a again i've i i
know even less than either of you about
this stuff but if
i could imagine kojima being the kind of
person who would get excited if there
was a game that said
we can leverage a server farm in a way
that
is
beyond what
like even the single most powerful
gaming rig could ever do like if there's
some if there's some thing that i'll
tell you what the game depends on like
some stick or some some calculation that
so there's there is one thing that plays
off exactly what you're describing which
is cloud-based there have been some
interesting experiments and some
companies that have tried different
things with this of basically simulating
enormous amounts of data
that is shared by
people like basically if you wanted to
make an mmo sorry
isn't the microsoft flight simulator an
example like that's a that's an example
but like if you want to make if you
wanted to make horizon zero dawn but you
wanted every animal in that world to be
a working simulation of a full eco
sphere that couldn't be run on your
local hardware it'd be pointless to do
so that could be data that is shared
across multiple players so there you
could have a cloud simulation running
that people are jumping into so they
wanted to see enormous data stop it
stop it
wash your mouth out that is we're not on
this podcast
but you but you but there are things
like that where i could see like a
complex of incredibly complex simulation
because we've kind of faded so something
like no man's sky pretends to have an
amazingly complex simulation but
actually it has very cleverly
brilliantly seeded randomness
um
which is which is repeatable because
it's seeded but yes if you want to run
some kind of super complex simulation
that was beyond what you could run on
piece of hardware and and then share
that between different players that
would be
i've seen that working there are there
of um oh gosh no no there's a british
company that's
uh other games
no
there's a british company that like has
that was worth value like billions of
dollars the royal family
um i think it's boris johnson's uh
government which i'm waiting i'm looking
forward to getting off this call and
finding out if he's still the prime
minister that's all right now
it's oh there's some drama in the uk
right now but don't worry about it and
by the time this comes out it will have
changed in five million ways but you
know the um
yeah that's a that's a use case i could
see someone figuring out really
good and i could see a kojima i could
see i could see with his the way he
conceives of things i could see that
being something along that wavelength
does strike me as plausible yeah of of
like a thing that is
truly alive and evolving in this in the
like i
the social aspect of death stranding was
one of the interesting x factors of that
game that i actually found myself
um
initially kind of put off by and then it
sort of grew on me the same thing with
eldon ring where improbably that's the
name of the company i was thinking of
sorry carry on oh are they british
company i guess uh based in the uk i
don't i don't know where they're filing
those they're the they're like the back
end tech uh
for
large server kind of they basically
anyone who's watched the last season of
uh silicon valley where they're like
reinvented reinventing like distributed
computing
in that's the company in real life
that's
theoretically trying to do that they're
making they've they're doing an original
game like using their leveraging they
funded a few things yeah they've they've
i've had i've had the pitch and the
whiteboard demonstration of how their
tech works and i understood well over 10
of it
yeah
yeah in any case that that to me that
kind of stuff is very exciting uh
totally uh that could be cool maybe
thinking of something that we aren't and
i will maybe that's the right maybe
that's the road
no one always bet on kojima that's all
i'll say always better kojima like they
asked me at my interview
at santa monica studio
for my opinion on hideo kojima they said
what do you think of hideo kojima games
and i was like that's a [ __ ] good
interview question because that's a
clever test bad answers to that that is
a good interview question you can also
use it to gauge like how professional
the person is like whether they like
just stop bad mouthing and street appear
in an interview which is a very easy
tell to look for i'm nicking that that's
a really good interest i thought so too
i was like oh you know what you do with
that question that's a good one uh what
was your answer where did you guys tell
you i'll tell you when we start
recording
in any case i do have to get back to you
now my lunch break is like he's wrong
about cloud computing
poor audience sorry audience a lot of
people video game writer that's my bill
who's a video game director that is
awesome he's a video game composer and
troy i guess disappeared at some point
internet problems yeah sorry about that
oh dog